what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today we actually have quite a bit of
news concerning spider-man no way home
of course venom 2 let there be carnage
and we got some new eternals news as
well a little rumor flying around for
the eternals and a big rumor going
around for spider-man no way home that i
really really hope is true we actually
have some venom let there be carnage new
footage and we have some information
about the pre-sales for the film which
are looking pretty good right now which
is also a very good sign that eventually
we're going to see spider-man and venom
go at it and ultimately i think you'll
really enjoy the spider-man rumor and
what it could mean for the future of the
spider-man franchise if it does indeed
turn out to be true so if you love
marvel and spider-man and want to stay
up to date on all things mcu be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos and big thank you to
scentbirds for sponsoring this video
more on them in a bit so this rumor for
spider-man knowing home is pretty cool
and i think a lot of people are going to
like this i think a lot of people in the
beginning were wondering when exactly
were toby mcguire spider-man and andrew
garfield spider-man going to be taken
from in their universe will they be
taken right after the final events of
their last films will some time have
gone by could they be married after all
shaylyn woody was supposed to play mj in
the amazing spider-man 2 so what exactly
can we expect from them in spider-man no
way home well according to a writer for
the
geeks worldwide aj they say that from
their understanding andrew is right
after the amazing spider-man 2 toby is
years after spider-man 3. and this is
very interesting if this turns out to be
true because andrew is going to be taken
right after the events of the last film
no time in between which means there's
not really going to be much more
development there it'll pretty much be
the same spider-man that we last saw
however toby maguire spider-man will
have had some time so he would have had
time for a lot of character development
and this is where it actually gets
really really interesting especially if
you combine it with other rumors that
we've heard before and those state that
he's going to be married to mj and he's
going to have a daughter this
particularly excites me because a
character that i've always wanted to see
is spiderling the daughter of mary jane
watson and peter parker her name is
annie parker and she inherited the
abilities from her dad of course however
she is a tiny bit more let's call it
enhanced her spider senses are actually
much more evolved than her father's so
she has precognition she can see events
in great detail before they happen and i
personally think that it would be really
cool to see spiderling on screen with
her father now unfortunately i don't
think we're going to be getting that in
spiderman no way home however a possible
setup could happen after all we are
getting the young avengers perhaps this
is another member of the young avengers
that could happen if somehow the
universes collide even more there has
been a lot of talk that we could be
getting a spider-man 4 with tobey
maguire a sam raimi spider-man 4 there
was supposed to be a fourth movie and we
never got it and there's been a lot of
talk lately about the possibility of
getting that movie there's also been a
lot of talk of andrew garfield sticking
around as well and i would really like
for this to happen because i know a lot
of people don't like the amazing
spider-man franchise but i truly do
think that andrew garfield really loved
the part did the best that he could and
was not a bad spider-man by any means i
don't think the failure of the franchise
or the movies was his fault and i think
he should get another chance and i
really do think it would be cool to see
the other two spider-man kind of stay
involved and i think this for two
reasons one obviously because i love the
other two spider-man and i would like to
see more films but two this would
actually mean something greater for tom
holland spider-man if they are going to
show toby maguire and andrew garfield
later on down the road even more that
means that their roles in no way home
don't have to be huge they come in to
help but they don't really take it away
from tom holland a lot of people have
really wanted him to go out on his own
and kind of not rely on anybody and i
think that we really still could get
that from this film but the biggest
thing here is that i think there's a lot
more happening than we actually know i
think sony and marvel studios have a lot
more plans with some of these other
spider-men down the road at least i
really really hope so and there have
been a lot of rumors nothing confirmed
yet but a lot of rumors talking about
this and as far as tom holland getting
some help from people i ultimately don't
think that he will get help if he ever
goes up against venom which i'm thinking
is going to happen especially if you
consider what tom hardy recently said
about venom and spider-man and i'll talk
about that in just a second but before
we continue please allow me to thank our
sponsors for today's video scentbird as
you know sponsors really help the
channel especially when they are super
cool sponsors like scentbird guys if
you're trying to get the attention of
that one special lady and ladies if
you're trying to smell great and get the
men to work harder this is for y'all
scentbird is a fragrance cologne and
perfume subscription service that gives
you the opportunity to shop from over
600 different brands and yes they do
have designer perfume and cologne brands
that you know and love and one of the
best parts is it's a flexible
subscription so you can skip any month
without any penalties now if you already
like fragrances or you're looking to get
some scentbird is the way to go why
because with each fragrance that you get
each month you'll get a 30 day supply so
you can try out fragrances before
committing to a full bottle like i
mentioned they carry designer brands
like prada gucci versace and more and
these are 100 authentic they work
directly with the brands and if you want
you can upgrade to receive two to three
products a month i've upgraded and this
month i chose english laundry prada and
sanctuary and i have to say i really
love the prada on the back it tells you
what comes in it lavender mint bitter
orange sage and musk and i chose these
because they're all very refreshing very
light very citrusy it smells like
springtime so if you're looking to up
your dating game or just be fresh be
sure to click the link in the
description down below and be sure to
use coupon code cosmic for 30 off your
first month's subscription for only 11
for your first month
now as i mentioned we do have some new
footage of venom let there be carnage
now it is mostly the same footage except
for a part at the end which is pretty
cool where we see kind of carnage
breaking out of some place i'm assuming
it's probably the prison but it looks
really really good and i'm thinking that
the action of this movie is actually
going to be better than the first which
obviously is great and venom 2 has a
pretty decent start to pre-sales right
now it's about half of what shanghi's
pre-sales were and they are expecting
around 45 to 55 million opening weekend
and this is pretty great news now the
reason why this is great news is because
tom hardy specifically talked about
venom 3 about a month or two ago and he
literally stated that the goal for venom
3 is to have tom holland spider-man in
it he said that's the goal that's the
olympic gold medal that he's going to go
for he said that he has to shoot for
that and if both studios are okay with
it that's what he wants venom 3 to be
and if you consider this combined with
the news that sony just changed the name
of their spider-man universe again from
the sp umc or the sony picture universe
of marvel characters which i hate so i'm
glad they changed it but now it's very
simple the name of the universe is
simply now sony's spider-man universe
and this is good news and it's pretty
much a sign that sony is actually going
to use spider-man no don't concern
yourself about spider-man in the mcu i
don't think he's going anywhere i do
however think he's going to jump
universes after all kevin feige stated
that a year ago more than a year ago
that tom holland spider-man is the only
character with the ability to jump
between universes and considering the
fact that they've changed their name
going to go ahead and say that
spider-man or spider-man is going to
appear in other sony films craven the
hunter morbius spider-woman or whatever
olivia wilde spider-woman project is
going to be called and eventually venom
hopefully venom 3 if tom hardy gets his
way so let's really hope that venom does
well because if it does that is good
news for a venom vs spider-man epic film
and also if you have three spider-man
and one movie you kind of gotta wonder
what do they have planned next how do
you go bigger or get fans excited well i
think venom versus spider-man would
definitely get fans really excited now
last but not least marvel did release
some eternals posters and they are quite
cool and i don't think people understand
just how big the eternal's film is going
to be and yes it is going to be a
massive film it's going to earn a lot of
money i'm sure in the cast is crazy big
but that's not actually what i'm
referring to i'm referring to the
implications and the repercussions that
i believe this film is going to have on
the mcu since the eternals are so old
and have been around since the very
beginning i think we're going to
actually discover a lot about the mcu
and then in current time after the snap
like we've seen in the trailers we're
also going to see some major
repercussions mostly probably concerning
the celestials and possibly if we're
lucky the mutants because after all the
eternals are directly connected to the
creation of the mutants so the eternals
could really be the start of something
very very huge in the marvel cinematic
universe and just visually it looks like
it's gonna be a beautiful movie these
posters are magnificent the trailers are
beautiful i can't wait to watch the
movie i hope it's a massive success so
be sure to let me know what you think
about the spider-man no way home rumors
the possibility of a venom versus
carnage face-off and let me know what
implications you think the eternals are
going to have on the future of the mcu
be sure to let me know in the comments
down below don't forget to like the
video and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter also
if you are interested in scentbird be
sure to click the link in the
description down below and be sure to
use code cosmic so you can get a
discount on your first month's order as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof